here we go my name is Rory McCann and I
play sandor clegane also known as a
hound
[Music]
the hound appears as The Bodyguard of
Joffrey and he's a brother looking
around his big brother
you can see that there's a there's a bit
of animosity going on the oh there's a
bit of a backstory going on there the
backstory is when Sandra was a kid he
borrowed his big brother and Gregor's
toy and was discovered playing with it
by Gregor Gregor went crazy and stuffed
pure Sanders feasts in the fire from
then on he was general minded with his
disfigurement of what happens in these
early days you know think I can have
shaped his character as well
Sandra at that time was meant to be
doing his duty
beside Joffrey but when he sees the
mountain attack Flores it brings him
back to Gregor's this big bully and he
breaks rank and fusion has to do
something yes but no time for bullies
it's got no time for Gregor and just
goes for it and is prepared to kill him
the right there and then into how the
hoenn just stops right away it shows you
that he is actually a loyal that he will
answer to the king I mean maybe just
snaps out of his rage as well he finds
the Brotherhood without banners has a
cup of tea and some rabbit over over the
fire he ought to join us we could use
you good and bad young and old the
things were fighting will destroy them
all and hide may be a is of some use and
maybe he can use this anger to to some
good this seems like a good place to
spend the night these people don't want
us here seems deserted to me he
recognizes that house right away he
doesn't want to go in but a he goes in
and he sees his predictions true and
he's say remorseful he decides to give
them a decent burial a thing that you
haven't really seen was the Hound and
then he sees visions and the fire in a
fire you know he's never seen this
before
it's where the wall meets the sea
there's a council there
efficiency seas are terrifying
and that motivates him to go with this
slot and God maybe they're right there's
something endless and this is serious
and maybe I can help
the plan is to go up beyond the wall
capture a white and bring it back to
King's Landing to prove what was coming
their way he's seeing this death he's
seeing it they're alive
the dead are coming towards them and
there's been a big fight
I left this [ __ ] city because I didn't
want to die in it am I gonna die in this
[ __ ] city you might this is a serious
polo with all the high head ones and he
throws up a load and very very
dangerously really he feels like he has
to get a message and go straight up to
his brother and go by the way I know
this is all pretty heavy stuff but just
to let you know your [ __ ] Gantner
remember me yeah you do it's not how it
ends for you brother you know he's
coming for you you've always known you
start but not all his life and he's not
gonna stop he's gonna complete that
mission he everybody is Charlie we got
more Game of Thrones Season eight promos
to break down time to talk about the
Hound versus the Mountain cleganebowl
get hype the show finally confirmed it
at the end of season 7 but it had been a
theory ever since before season 3 aired
it actually started out as a book theory
a couple of different theories that
morphed into what cleganebowl eventually
became because George are Martin even
laid in teasers as early as book one
when bran is having visions that the TV
show cut out that's one of the reasons
why it took the TV show so long to get
to so many big payoffs because you get a
lot of that through brands visions that
they just did not do we're doing a new
round of the Song of Ice and Fire book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video however you feel about the
current version of the mountain on the
TV show half your bjornsen i think i'm
pronouncing his name correctly he's
great for what the TV show is using him
for right now he's almost literally a
mountain compared to other people
Rory McCain's performance of the Hound
has been fantastic this entire time I
wasn't quite as focused on the character
in the early books before I'd actually
watched the TV show and in in the early
seasons of the TV show you know he was a
curiosity but not necessarily the
biggest character he just had a couple
really big moments that stood out
especially at Robert's tourney where he
actually tries to fight his brother for
the first time albeit stopped short by
Robert it was really books 2 book 3
season 2 season 3 of the TV show where
he really started to break away and
become way more complicated way more
interesting like he started to focus
more on protecting Sansa he had his
EPIK f the king moment then he threw in
with Arya Stark in near the beginning of
their relationship which is probably one
of the more interesting pairings that
the TV show has ever done but the
cleganebowl of it all didn't really
start out in the books until feast for
crows and it looked like Cersei was
going to get a trial with the faith
which the TV show really didn't get to
till like tail-end season 5 season 6 but
what happened was that after Arya and
the season 4 finale refused to kill the
Hound and leaves him for dead
you just didn't know what was going to
happen to him till we saw him again
during season 6 so that's really when
the TV show cleganebowl Theory started
to explode because a lot of it had spun
out of theories about what was going on
on the quiet Isle that the Hound was
secretly the gravedigger so there were
actually a couple of different theories
that morphed together to become what is
now clicking bow that people talk about
when Brienne of Tarth still in the
middle of her quest to find Sansa Stark
travels to the quiet Isle thinking that
she might be hiding out there with
Podrick Payne
inhale hunt she sees Stranger which was
the hounds horse so a lot of book
readers had theorized that that person
was the Hound separately after feast for
crows people expected Cersei to get a
trial with the faith and actual trial
and for her to choose Robert strong as
her champion who at that time had not
been revealed to be the mountain
although most book readers said assumed
that that was the case but this was all
happening way before season four in
season five before the TV show had ever
done that so this is still firmly a book
theory
so people assuming that Cersei would
choose Robert strong were listing people
that could potentially fight for the
faith if the faith had to choose their
own champion because of the separate
gravedigger theory people assume that
the Hound had found some sort of
religion or peace in his exile and that
the faith would reach out to him and he
was the only person who could fight his
brother which if you've ever heard Rory
McCann the actor talk about the hounds
relationship with the brother he talks
about it that same way too like he's one
of the few people in Westeros that could
actually match him blow-for-blow
somatically they had so much history and
unfinished business between each other
it would just make sense it'd be a big
payoff for the fans that they would
eventually fight each other
but what happened was is that the TV
show took a left turn in Tommen outlawed
trial by combat
that's why TV show Cersei blew up the
great set during season six that was her
option B otherwise she would have chose
trial by combat
so r.i.p Tommen he has
only himself to blame for that but the
cool thing is is that even as early as
book 1 George our Martin himself
foreshadowed cleganebowl in this vision
that Brandt has I think it's actually
out of chapter 17 but keep in mind that
this would have been happening during
season 1 when everyone's slowly making
their way to King's Landing so brain is
having a vision in the passage just
reads when bran looks down again he can
see the whole realm and everything in it
in Winterfell he sees the inhabitants
going about their work and sees the
heart tree in the godswood looking back
at him bran sees his mother
contemplating a blood-stained knife
aboard a ship sailing on the Narrow Sea
that's talking about the cat's-paws
Valyrian dagger and his father pleading
with the king near the Trident he sees
Sansa crying herself to sleep in Arya
holding her secrets in her heart then we
get to the clicking bolt part of the
vision and it reads all around his
family bran sees shadows when his
darkest ash with a terrible face of a
hound in another in an armor as golden
and beautiful as the Sun over them looms
a giant armored in stone but with only
darkness and black blood behind its
visor so it seems like bran is having a
vision of Robert strong who at the time
we didn't quite know was the mountain
but when he's talking about looking
behind his visor he's seen the
appearance through the mounts it has
once Qyburn brings him back in his
appearance changes so even though that
doesn't give you a lot of details about
the win or the why it just is implied
that the Hound would eventually face the
mountain even if you were unsure about
the season 7 finale moment between them
Rory McCann the actor talking about it
in real life is very clear that they are
going to finish their unfinished
business so how do they pay that off we
do have like a basic idea of the
structure of season 8 for the most part
we don't know everything that's going to
happen but we do know early in the
season they're gonna have all those
reunions up at Winterfell they'll also
start preparing for their first big
battle with the night king in the White
Walkers so this is still in the early
part of the season then in the later
episodes there's the idea of a second
big conflict down near King's Landing
that would be the time to pay off
Clegane bull so it doesn't necessarily
confirm that the Hound is going to
survive the first big battle against the
night king and the White Walkers but if
they're gonna pay off cleganebowl and
they can't do it til he's down at King's
Landing and everyone's gonna be stuck up
at Winterfell for the first half of the
season you just do the reverse calculus
on that in his
the directors and the actors are hyping
up this big battle with the night king
and the White Walkers up at Winterfell
it they're calling it like a big
40-minute battle in a single episode so
it'll be crazy there's the idea that it
might get even crazier when they move
down to King's Landing because there's
so many story threads and so many
character relationships that you have to
pay off so much unfinished business
between the big main characters so even
though they're not necessarily main
characters the Hound versus the mountain
is just one of the most exciting things
that I'm looking forward to in this
season but let me know in the comments
when during season 8 do you think that
they're gonna pay off clicking bowl-like
do you think they'll save it for the end
of the season down at some big battle at
King's Landing
or do you think it'll happen at some
other point and everybody wants to know
when they're gonna drop that first big
season 8 trailer usually they drop those
3 months to the day before the season
premieres so because it's gonna premiere
at the end of April I'm just expecting
the trailer to drop somewhere near the
end of January but if I hear any news I
will totally post an update and one of
my Game of Thrones videos no worries if
you have any specific requests for a
Game of Thrones video leave it in the
comments below
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video ice blade films please
email me on the about page my channel so
I can get your contact details click
here for the Jon Snow and Daenerys
season 8 promo
and click here for my playlist of all
the other Game of Thrones season a
proposed thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight